this past weekend oh right all right
check check are we cruising
okay we're cruising right there
let's get going right here it is Monday
July 17th and welcome to this past
weekend I'm Theo von appreciate you guys
joining me I'm in Orlando I'm in Orlando
Florida I know the audio is kind of bad
in here I had a set up shop next to this
sink and one of those loud refrigerators
you know I think a lot of a lot of these
like mid-level hotels they put in the
refrigerator in the room it's 90 it's
never never keeps anything cold it
basically is just something loud in the
corner it's almost like a pet it's like
having a grandparent you know that has
dementia but that has like adult asthma
you know or that kind of snores a little
while be sleeping there's always you
know there's those they're always just
um it's just too much man it's always
just it's like a rattle like the thing
always just sort of rattles a little bit
like that is it
yeah it'll just kind of click on even
though it's on all the time every now
and then the the frigerator just sounds
like it just cuts like haha like
somebody startled it or something you
know like somebody just tried to shove
something up its freezer section I don't
know I'm in Orlando man it's late at a
long day I'm about to get into it but I
want to thank you guys for joining me I
hope you had a good weekend you know I
think a lot of people are still enjoying
some of that fourth of July honest and
you know a little bit of that aftermath
of a of Labor Day and vacation time and
and I went to Disneyworld man I went to
Disney World this weekend that's
probably the biggest thing that I did I
was down here at the Orlando Improv and
I went to Disney World and I don't know
if you've been down to Disney but I have
before I went twice I went once
child my mother saved up some money I'm
sure and took my brother and I to Disney
World
my father didn't go he was probably a 75
at the time and he stayed at home and
our mom took us in ah and and I only
have a few maybe vague recollections
from that just still images in my head
but I went to Disney World when I was in
high school and we took acid we took
some LSD now this was a time when people
were experimenting with drugs which is
all the time in America
you know if you've ever been around or
opened your eyes in America
you'll see people on drugs and we went
there we took a bus from Louisiana over
to Orlando Florida here where I am right
now and we stayed in some [ __ ] motel and
it was a school organized trip and they
brought us down and and I remember on
the bus I've been seeing a gal at the
time in high school I remember we're
making love on the bus I remember that
you know getting in the middle of the
night I remember you know her you know
just escalating her body on top of me
and making love and make really making
that joy adding more joy to that bus
ride than usual bus rides because I've
been on some other bus rides and I'm
happy to talk about those and I would
like to just while I'm thinking about it
let's make that the topic for next week
if you have been on a wild bus ride I'm
talking greyhound or a bus adventure of
some sort Peter Pan you know one of
those troubled bus lines and if you've
had a wild experience you can hit the
hotline and let me know about that and
we'll try to drop some of those in for
next week that number is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three now
back to your regularly scheduled program
so we got down to Orlando and somebody
had some acid and so we took some acid
you know a little bit LSD and I remember
if something was in this LSD it made
everybody look Asian you know if I don't
know if we you know if the guy who had
gotten it had copped it off of a you
know an Asian guy
iõve Dora you know a Cambo Cambodian the
column cam bows a lot of people but but
we had that Vietnamese acid or whatever
it was a Cambo acid and I remember
everybody I looked at location you know
and I got 10 eyes so game recognized
game but when I'm on that acid and
everybody it just made everybody look
Asian so we came there and it was like
graduation night and all of my high
school buddies probably about eight or
nine people on acid didn't tell the rest
of the class and we're just running
around it's a small world we probably
went on that about nine times some kid
kept drinking the water out of Pirates
of the Caribbean and he got sick he
drank probably about two gallons of it
and he got pretty sick but we just spent
the whole night on acid running around
and doing the different rides and being
scared of each other and being scared of
ourselves and hiding in the bathroom and
like six of us tried to split a
hamburger that's how geeked out we were
and couldn't even do it couldn't even
eat it but that was a good time and that
was part of high school you know but
that was the last time I've been at
Disney World and that was only one of
two senior trips and we taken another
senior trip to Mexico Mexico you know
one of the larger countries south of
America and we got down there and
everybody I remember bought a bunch of
prescription pills and was doing was
stealing each other stuff I mean it
wasn't but a couple of probably nine
hours we were down there in Cancun and
half a class and this was a senior trip
in high school half the class was you
know hopped up on prescription pills and
stealing each other's luggage and
selling each other's [ __ ] on the streets
and you know getting stealing each
other's whatever it was at the time we
didn't have cell phones we had those
calculators ti-85 s as fancy you know
you laters and we were you know those
number crunchers you know that dude
though they do algebra and we were
stealing those and selling them and
buying more pills and I mean
a group of 17 or 18 19 year olds it only
took us about about 12 hours to go
completely AWOL and half of us be
addicted to painkillers and out there
selling each other's goods and and
different type of textiles and wares so
that got that got bad and everybody's
fighting and it's and our half of us
were sharing a room and I'm were
stealing stuff from each other and
hiding it in the same room we were
eating so that right there will tell you
what some prescription pills will do to
you you know so that's one thing you
just stay off of but anyhow that was uh
and a lot more happen on that trip but
that was some of those high school trips
in one of those was Disney Disney town
Florida and I'm here this weekend in
Orlando Florida and and some lovely
ladies miss Suzanne and Megan they just
hit me up actually on the hotline and
they said dia we would love to take you
to Disney World and I said I would love
to go and jiggy he's a comedian as Wells
name is jiggy and he's a white guy cuz
you think jiggy
you know you think it's more of a urban
hip-hop name you know jiggy but it's not
it's a white jiggy and he's a very funny
comedian he tours with the Impractical
Jokers and he's a great guy no ego on
this young man really great guy but he
came along with us as well and he met
some little bird the night before she
came so we got a motley crew out there
at the out there at Dee and his friend
Giovanna came as well so we had a we had
a great little crew out there at Disney
World we got there early out of the gate
I was up at 8 a.m. did not want to be
awake did not want to go see the mouse
but we got there and it was a great time
and we we got a little bit of Sun you
get there and you park and then you get
on the tram and it seemed a lot more
like a theme park than it did like a
magical kingdom that's where we went we
went to Magic Kingdom but when I was
young I remember even in high school it
seemed like wow Disney World you know
but as an adult now
it seemed a little bit more just like a
theme park you know like okay it's you
know you get you go on the ride you wait
in the lines it's not as more of the
magic was for the youth I found but it
was very picturesque you know they had
to castle I mean there's a hundred
degrees you've got the little gerbils
out there chipmunks you know Alvin and
Simon and the or whoever they are and
they're out there you know just sweating
I mean you could just see their fur just
drenching up at the paws and at the
elbows from the sweat and they didn't
even have a lot of you know Alice
Wonderland was out there but she looked
man she looked like she'd been through
some things you know like she'd been
living in Reno for a little bit but we
got there and you get on the tram and
they take you first of all they take you
right past where the little baby got
eaten by the alligator we fought the
alligator and I used to have dreams a
lot of times when I was younger where
babies would be fighting animals and so
it's hard for me to not say it's hard
for me to say I haven't seen animals and
babies fight each other because I have
you know I haven't seen it live you know
I don't even think I don't know if you
can see that even in Mexico or in maybe
rush I bet you probably still see some
of that that type of you know gambling
activity and such but but um but in my
dreams I've seen it often I remember
they had a tournament one time over
about a week and a half and I was
sleeping not consecutive sleeping but in
the evenings you know rest and catch and
rest and I would have these different
dreams of different babies and animals
in this big tournament and fighting each
other and fighting each other off and um
and and then you know it kept narrowing
down and narrowing down until you had
one animal that won and that animal was
a I want to say it was a Lynx I believe
large cat dark kind of looking black cat
but a not a black cat like you see just
on your street or on a side street a
black cat you have to really get into
the woods to see you know kind of like
the evil black cat in Jungle Book
something like that but it it
pretty strong baby in the last kind of
dream that I've had but anyhow I'm
getting tangential here but let me tell
you this so you drive right past the
place where that baby fought that
alligator and lost and so that's a
little crazy out of the gate because you
haven't even gotten to the magic and
then they got this I mean you literally
go right over the beach we've all seen
the pictures of the beach and the you
know the roped-off area where you know
the alligator just snatched up that baby
and so that's wild because that you've
just seen that and you get there and and
then you get to to the park and you go
in and see the Magic Castle
and a friend of mine one of the friends
that went with us this young lady Gio
she was telling us that they there's a
whole underground city there at Disney
and I'm like wow you know this is very
much like Vietnam you know when you
think about it because you know the
Vietnamese they would really they had
these um the kuchi tunnels and because
you're not free you can look that up and
that spelled see you CH I I think
separate words but the kuchi tunnels
where the Vietnamese would hide in the
ground and then dr. buck buck buck buck
buck buck just poke you out with with uh
you know bamboo spikes up through the
ground and surprise you and kill you and
uh but Disney's not like that you know
they're trying to show you enjoy but
they have a whole underground city
apparently where the you know the Disney
at nummies if you will are down there is
just subbing out Chipmunks and subbing
out you know dancing raccoons and wild
animals or you know Winnie the Pooh
whoever their characters are that are on
the lot that day that are you know if
they're rocking you know a regular
ground they got it where you're where
they're subbing each other out and kind
of piping each other in and out so it's
pretty it was just crazy to just even
hear that and then you'd see some of the
activity you'd see like somebody you
know used to like oh oh this crazy
walrus from you know from the
oldest movie he'll disappear around a
building and then you see another walrus
come out and he'd be like maybe just a 2
inches taller you know you're like oh
look at that walrus you know I know he
didn't just grow behind that building so
you know it's just interesting to start
to see some of the inner workings of it
you know if you really as an adult
you're able to take a you know you're
not as mesmerized by the childhood
enumerations of it all and you were able
to be able to actually see some other
stuff that's going on so I thought that
was really really captivating to me just
to be able to have that experience of
seeing Disney from a more adult
standpoint what else do we do there saw
a lot of male ponytails and I know
that's a Florida thing and I don't like
it you know they have the man bun an
honest outing the man bun looks kind of
handsome you know you see some fellows
with it but that male the male ponytail
that says it's just gutter you know it
is gutter and it really a lot of men if
they had that they got issues you know
this is actually jiggy calling on my paw
he's calling right now I got to take it
because I got to see if you're going to
bring me some food hey bud yeah I'm back
at the hotel I was doing my podcast
right now
Monica Sam was just anything you run
across over there will be good my room
number is 523 where are you where you at
okay cool man I'll see a little bit all
right sorry about that man get me a
little sandwich coming it's a midnight
here and we're catching a 5 a 5 no 7 7
a.m. flight where we're going to leave
at 5:15 so it's going to be that kind of
night what else do you add isni was wild
man we had a great time when I'm a few
of the rides and it's you know the rides
aren't too scarier the Roger to make you
feel joy and it did
Leave Act sum up to being a kid The
Haunted Mansion and just seeing like you
I wasn't really looking at the rides as
thinking what what does this look like
to me this experience I was more as an
adult I was trying to think back I was I
found myself trying to feel like a child
I found myself trying to like look out
at the Raj and be like wow wonder what
this was like when I was a kid or I
wonder what a kid would be thinking
right now if they saw this
so it's interesting it's um it's a great
place to be a kid man it's a great place
to kind of reconnect with some of that
or to connect with some of that at all
because it's just built so much I
believe around the mindset of you know
of Wow engaging man we had we really had
a great time and I just want to thank
the young ladies that took us one of
them's husband is a fireman and he got
us some passes so thank you Ryan I know
that's the man's name he didn't even
come so he actually he lent us his wife
for the afternoon and that was kind of
him so thank you very much had a good
time we had a really good time it was
just uh it was a blast man and they had
some fast passes as some of the rods you
could you know get in a quicker line and
we had a blast so thank you very much
outside of that I went and saw an old
friend I had a friend that hadn't seen
in 20 years that lived here in Orlando
and I went and saw him and it's
interesting to see no print because they
have pieces of your life that you forgot
you know they have different pieces of
the story they have different elements
and we really shared some stories and
I'm gonna get into some of those I'll
get into some of those next week just
some more stories from home and stuff
but uh but that was interesting just to
rekindle just kind of that it that that
vibe in that environment and and he had
a buddy over they were making a brisket
right he had a buddy from I think his
friend was from Israel or England so he
had a buddy over making a brisket
and so I get over there I'm thinking you
know we in a little while you know I got
over there probably one I'm thinking
we'll leave probably 2:30 about 3:45 I'm
like damn dude I'm hungry you know like
if you invite somebody over for some
brisket you probably need to have some
brisket at some point you know and I
don't mean to get angry but you need to
do what you say you're going to do when
it comes to feeding people because
people are hungry and if they don't eat
they'll die it's different if I say come
over I'll lend you a pair of shoes and I
don't that's fine you got other shoes
you got skin on your feet you know you
know your body's not going to just fall
out of the bottom of your legs you have
skin on your feet that is going to hold
your body together but if you tell
somebody to eat is they're going to eat
they're not and this got nicest guy but
he kept trying to be a fancy chef you
know he's like oh well let me know you
know I got the meat and then where I'm
gonna sweat it I'm gonna sweat the meat
you know I'm gonna take it off the grill
and put it into a nice thing and then
I'm gonna I'm just gonna stare at it you
know I'm gonna get in a staring contest
with this meat and see who you know show
it who's boss and I might dude I don't
give a [ __ ] who's boss you know I don't
care about this meats work history you
know I don't need to see a resume I want
to eat bro
and finally after all this [ __ ] of just
flipping it in the air and [ __ ] you
know dusting it with you know cumin and
damn dust powder and smoke and this
guy's like I you know he kept pulling
the fat off of it and injecting it back
into it and like recycled and reused and
refurbished and Jesus Christ reborn
born-again brisket I'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on dude I'm but the only
place you need to baptize this [ __ ]
piece of meat is in my mouth Brother
Bear and so man some of this chef thing
though is just going too far you know
and you got these friends it's like dude
we're here to eat like we've been
swimming in a pool you know hanging out
with the children every having a nice
time we got sunburned just [ __ ] eat
you know we're not saving the world out
here you know so finally I had to get a
little fiery you know not with the guy
really but just with the overall idea of
what was going on because you invited me
here to eat guess what buddy bear I'm
hungry so let's do it
oh but nonetheless we had a good time my
friend came out to the show with his
wife last night it was good to catch up
with an old friend ma'am pretty pretty
pretty good anyway
sometimes you invite friends and they
end up like kind of they end up being
the loudest one at the show and I
actually had a girl that came out this
weekend and she brought some friend or
something and you know this is a gallon
I'm from years ago she brought her best
friend and her that lady's husband and
they sat and talked in the audience the
whole time and I'm like are you kidding
me like and it always happens every time
you bring your friends there's this
thing that friends just feel like
they're part of the show you know and
it's not bad sometimes but sometimes it
was some of this bad but but we made the
most time we made it through Thank You
Orlando I had a great weekend man I
really did I really really did we got
some cool calls it hits a hotline I'm
trying to think of it as anything else
wanted to go with you guys I'm going to
drop some quick dates on you right now
and those dates are I will be in San
Diego this Thursday July 20th and that
is with Sal from Impractical Jokers and
Roy Wood jr. from The Daily Show and
that is at the House of Blues they don't
be in Montreal Canada Montreal and that
is a July 27th through the 30th I'll be
in Texas Dallas Texas at the Addison
improv August 10th through the 13th
let's get out to that one I'll show some
love that's my favorite Club very
excited about that and then September
6th through the 9th I will be in Addison
Texas that's where we are right now I
might add a date in Vancouver I'm just
not sure if people would come out to it
if so I'll do that next week we'll see
I'm looking into that right now
but thank you got to your love and
support you can get the album's right
now thirty pound bag of hamster bones
and must get fire those are both
available on iTunes
and please subscribe to the podcast we
got some new shirts that will be going
up at the end of the week on Theo von
comm slash store and that's it man I
love you guys we've got some we had some
calls that came in man some neat stuff I
wanted to get to so let's get into it
man and this is a follow up this guy
called in it was a couple weeks late but
I'm guessing he just heard the episode
and he called in talking about talking
about America and then we'll move on to
some different stuff here we go all
right hold on see a video it's Trevor
from California just heard of your last
this past weekend and wanted to give you
a quick call thank you for calling
Trevor happy to have you calling in from
California let's hear it you were
talking about what it means to be an
American and I thought all the colors at
great points and as always you provided
some good feedback too but I'm kind of a
I guess more of like a philosophical
side and Trevor's talking about you know
we we talked about what it meant to be
an American of his first time you've
heard this podcast we talked about it we
had some callers call in just what it
meant after fourth of July what they
felt like it meant onward I wonder what
what do you think about the point the
counterpoint I should say that really
nationalism and any sense of I'm an
American or I'm a Canadian our names for
our separation as humans it's a
different way to label ourselves as
something separate from one another and
I can kind of tell you know from
listening to you all this time that
you're more kind of and maybe I'm wrong
but you seem to be more of like a
brother you know universal brotherhood
you know all one type of thinking so how
do you square the fact that yes it's
good to be proud to be an American but
at the same time the more you believe
and especially psychologically and
philosophic
if you really believe you are an
American that preach of them and us or
us and them sort of dynamic which then
really is the root cause of all war and
conflict is yeah and I'll just pause you
right there Trevor I appreciate the
comment and you know it's funny I've
been thinking about this I've been
thinking about this since some of the
calls and since we went over that topic
some and this is kind of the other side
of that coin you know some of our calls
and stuff we're a little bit not
one-sided but it was those were those
are the people that called so those are
the things that we talked about but this
is another view and it's a great point
that Trevor makes that if we say that
okay I'm an American in Europe Canadian
in Europe you know an Ethiopian and
you're from Siam and you're from Mexico
then by having it like a pride in our
country are we separating ourselves you
know are we not looking at the fact you
to say hey we're all people and we're
all here in this world but instead we're
saying I'm this and you're that so is
having and I'm not trying to juxtapose
your point Trevor and I appreciate it
and you said it real clearly but it's
like is is that is that bad and it's
interesting man it's a great point you
know it's like if I mean right when I
heard your call Trevor really made me
think because I'm like wow yeah like if
I'm thinking just you know America
America then am I like immediately I'm
separating myself from other places you
know it should is all about people one
part one love you know one everyone and
I do I believe in the idea of
Brotherhood I believe that it would be
great if we could all live in
conjunction that way
I worry though that we I first of all I
think that if we're going to be able to
do that in the world that America is
gonna have to probably lead the way I
don't know if that's true maybe everyone
this has to lead the way but I think
that we seem to be looked at as a leader
a lot of times and if and if and if we
don't take care all right hold on one
second guys
I got Ziggy coming over to snack
good really whoa our foes be good you'll
be good man beautiful there sorry what
Giggy is lady is still with him his lady
this little uh some little betty Ruxpin
that he met yesterday and a sweet girl -
really cute named sarah really nice and
they met and they started holding hands
right at the theme park at Disney Disney
World today right out of the gate and
they met yesterday I don't know when
they met I'm not assuming they slept
together and like that but you know they
probably set slept close to each other
in a may be in the same room I don't
know and I guess I'm putting them on
blast now but it just saw but anyhow um
they're still together and they were
holding hands at the theme park that's a
wild move early like at 9:00 a.m. we got
there at 8:30 so if you start holding
hands early in the day dude what then
it's like every time your hands getting
near each other you have to hold again
cuz you started early started that train
already so he's really been caught up
but she's a sweet girl and he's and he's
a great dude anyhow so look but yeah
that's that's wild Trevor's wall to
think about you know like by having
American product we separating ourselves
and I think that that that if we don't
that accompany that a company that does
a business it doesn't take inventory
usually doesn't last long and that's
kind of where I think we are in America
I think we have the ability to set that
example and to be that example and even
to lead the world hopefully into that
one love Universal everyone environment
but I think it's got to be done steps at
a time like I think we need a serious
roll call in America of who's here
because you don't take inventory you
know you're not going to be in business
long and then
I mean if we just open the borders right
now everyone would come here we're
already really destined for an
overpopulation problem in America I
think a lot of people would come here
and I think it would if violence would
start to happen pretty quick you know I
mean I like to think that yes there's
all good in people in that that's the
way it would end up you know that we
would all share maybe that is the way we
go but are we going to do that you know
I don't know if we are I don't know if
we're just going to open and just let
everybody in the whole whoever wants to
come in come in to American I know it's
like you're saying well it's not our
America we're just living here we're
just passing through time and this is
our land yes I agree with that
we are but we have to if we want the
best to continue to be possible then I
think our to be possible then I think we
have to you know monitor the situation
where we're at and I think where we're
at right now is that America needs a
roll call you know always had a day
where everywhere they made everybody go
out in the street and see who your
neighbor is see who is here we'll even
know who is in America you know and I
feel like that's just kind of a scary
place to be you know I would do some
things different to start bringing
people back together you know we could
use a bit of closeness in America
getting people back together before we
start inviting everybody into this you
know greed money driven society that we
kind of have created you know I wish
that on Sunday night I wish they shut
the power out I remember when the power
was out my family used to spend time
together it was one of the only times
that we would spend time together was
when the power was out and it was just
something about it it was just peaceful
you know somebody had to light a candle
and we had to just be around each other
and we couldn't fight or anything
because we were everybody's a little bit
scared and you get this feeling like you
need each other and and I kind of I
thought that I think I'd be interesting
if we did that in America from Sunday
nights
you know after 5:00 p.m. no more power
shut it down so what you can't do
business you can't do whatever
oh well you can be with each other
you know you can spend time you can
create some of that love because I don't
know if we're really you know I think if
you if you just let everybody in and I
think in in a matter of a month you'd
have severe civil unrest you'd have the
rich all hiding
and be able to hide and you just have
straight-up anarchy in the streets Game
of Thrones style maybe I'm wrong maybe
I'm wrong but I mean look what happens
in when there's just a you know when
there's always gonna say like look what
happens in like a Katrina type
environment when people don't have what
they need
you know things escalate pretty quick
it's not a level of let's be peaceful
and figure this out things escalate
pretty quick you know but who but but I
love this thought though it's it's so
true that's the other side of the coin
it's like is this our country not really
you know we were just born here how do
we manage that and it's an it's an it's
an it's a that's an infective thought
that I wish that I'd like to think about
more because I feel like it's it's good
for me to think about that so Trevor I
appreciate you calling in and bringing
that to to my just to my brain man bring
it to the forefront of my brain a little
bit more from Trevor let's hear a little
more than us so just wanted to hear what
you have thought about that um didn't to
make a huge jump to and start with a
long message but I also do have a couple
of odd sana interactions for as you
mentioned you're looking he said sauna
interaction now we had people last week
I asked listeners if they wanted to call
and share about if they'd ever been hit
on by men or women in a sauna if it has
some sauna activities or even actually
here let's just assume the trimmer'
they're looking for where basically guys
will hit on you as I think you mentioned
when they were sleeping though which is
kind of a different thing but I could
certainly give you yeah because some men
be hitting on another men while they
sleep and you know and I remember
falling asleep at this older man's house
one time and I wake up and he trying to
be by me
you know and I didn't really know this
man that well and that was kind of wild
and and sometime if you're in a sauna
you know somebody is so foggy in there
next thing you know you turn your head
and there is somebody else's right there
or somebody's hip or thigh or you know
that soft area behind their knee or the
small of their back is right up under
your nose you know and things can get
surprising so that kind of stuff happens
in saunas some of that detail if if that
was useful but I wanted to focus on the
the nationalism piece and I appreciate
it Trevor appreciate : and the
nationalism thought it's great man it's
a great thought you know what if we were
just able to look at the world as this
is our nation instead of like Oh America
you know the world humanity and I think
it's a beautiful idea I don't know if
we're in a place right now where we can
easily realize like how do we trust it
that's going to occur if we're able to
you know if you open up the borders how
do you assure people that everybody's
just you know that if it's a
free-for-all that everybody's just going
to be good to one another you know I
don't know how that ends I mean I
remember if you look at even like the
story in the Bible and even if you don't
believe in the Bible which is fine if
you don't but if you just look at it as
a as a fable as a you know as a example
you know dad can enable that Adam and
Eve can enable for people on earth and
one of the brothers killed the other one
you know Cain killed Abel I believe so
at one point you had four people and and
one of them killed
what another person that's four people
so at one point you only have four
people one of the murderer you know like
it's risky bro that's risky and that's a
buddy of mine Matt Knutson has a great
joke about that and that idea is his
premise you can look that up though Matt
Knudsen talks about how one point in
time 25% of the population were
murderers if you believe in the Bible
all right let's keep it cruising here
what do we have
all right here we go hey Theo if Ethan
I love the podcast hey Ethan I like that
name eat and onward Thank You Ethan
yeah I'm calling because uh I married
for the four years so this woman who
doesn't really have sex with me anymore
Wow that is uh sounds like most
marriages probably my thoughts though
honestly lucky you dude sex sometimes
overrated bro onward I recently got in
really good shape
super helpful you're getting a lot of
attention from other girls and my sex
drive has gone up um so my wife is
really into it like me once every three
months and it's really kind of overdone
this fast
um okay so his wife only one Sammy said
about once every three months okay so I
can imagine that that's uh that's has
probably got to not make you feel very
good you know or at least it's got to
really diminish the returns on you
guys's love there probably if she
doesn't even feel attracted to you
onward so I kind of was lacking so I
resorted to trying to find someone
outside of the relationship to so show
that need anyways I met this girl we
started talking and like right from the
get-go is [ __ ] amazing she's
incredible every message was perfect
there's so much momentum it was
effortless it was awesome so that's been
going on for like five weeks now okay so
you got your dinner at the house and you
love and looking at the candy that's
what that sounds like let's hear a
little bit more I met this girl twice
you never had sex but that's kind of the
whole intense behind it but now I like
to so mean so much to me that I don't
know what to do okay so I'm just going
to stop here for just a second or pause
you see you you met this girl twice
you've been texting a lot you met her
twice there's the intent for sex hasn't
happened yet and you're saying you care
about her so much and that sounds
by confusing to me I mean I understand
that it can feel real to you but it
sounds from an outsider's perspective
which is what you're you know trying to
get here I assume that you know we that
she can't there can't it can't be that
you care about her so much because care
I would feel like takes more time to
actually establish itself so there's
probably a strong bit of a infatuation
unless you feel so uncared-for by your
wife that that any care at all here is
is really fulfilling that so much that
it just it feels like a ton of care or
it actually feels like care in that
infatuation onward and I know it's
probably common that it just finds
another girls and falls in love with her
for whatever reason because of what
lacking in place but actually address
the whole sex scene with my wife
recently and she confirmed uh she's is
not really into it had a panic attack a
couple nights ago thinking about it
again woke up with a millinery tonight
vomiting some anxiety just so I feel
like I'm floating in an emptiness
between two people who want me for
different reasons and no one actually
wants me for who I am as a whole Wow I
mean we just went through like an
emotional Star Wars right there so
you're you got anxiety from what's going
on here you talked to your wife about it
I'm assuming you talked about the sex
party not about the part that you have
you know this uh this little kitty on
the side you trying to pet this side
kitty you know and I've been out there
look man you know I have no I've had
trouble in relationships in the past as
why don't get in them commitment issues
and you know you start getting confused
in your feelings you want to touch that
side kitty you know when you will know
you know you might be even sitting in
the living room with your family but you
reaching your hand out back the window
and you Patton yard animals you feel me
you reach them for them soft wet yard
animals and that can happen man and it
sounds like you're starting to look for
that because if you have this in this
and this woman
then you're starting to feel that you
talk to your wife now you have an
anxiety you're vomiting in the night I
mean that could be I mean uh you know
what they if you eat a lot of times
peanut butter and jelly have a net for
you get a bit can really make you vomit
but especially if it's on raisin bread
because a lot of raisins and raisin
bread can be rotten if you guys knew
that a friend of mine just told me that
recently anyhow ah did it sounds like
you okay let's listen to the rest of
this onward and this other girl kind of
solved for me really hard and I did for
her and I think it threatened our own
situations so we're figuring that out
but I'm just really afraid she's going
to just going to ditch me I just want to
keep her in my life in some way even if
we're not having sex just wondering if
you had any advice on how I can handle
this I have an idea tried everything
don't know what to do okay man
appreciate your call and I do want to
say that man first and foremost I
appreciate you calling you like this
girl that sounds like the side kitty you
found some love or excitement you know
maybe that's missing from your
relationship and that's why it feels so
grandiose I think you got to ask you
yourself do you love your wife and do
you want to be with your wife you know
if not into me from this call I'm not
trying to give you advice but it sounds
like you're not getting what you need
there and at a certain point there's a
couple solutions or a couple of
directions you can try to get some
therapy for you and her together you can
try to get some therapy for yourself you
know because are you trying to solve the
problem with your wife or are you trying
to are you trying to to secure the issue
with your wife by reaching outside of
your marriage that's kind of a deal you
know and I would think about it in the
way try and treat your wife the way that
you would want to be treated so say the
roles are reversed and your wife has the
same you know you're you're not sexually
attracted to her
she's having these thoughts and feelings
and she's talking to somebody else how
would you best like it and be
understanding for her to deal with you
and then that's the way I would go out
and deal with her cuz you're not going
to be able to keep somebody around you
asked how do I keep this woman around on
the side you're not going to be able to
do that just as a friend you know
because you'll end up banging them you
know you will end up banging them or you
know laying next to them and jerking off
or something or doing some you know you
know just letting you know your innards
start to really express themselves you
know let your dick stand up just you got
to keep that in your head man you know
if you hang out with wool you're going
to lay your head on it that's what they
say
you know that's what they say many said
they said the man that sleeps with
sheeps skeets with sheeps so remember
that man keep that in your head if you
hang out with the wool you're going to
lay your head on it rarely do you see a
man walking around with a pillow and
then come nighttime he just set the
pillow in a briefcase or something no
but it sounds like infatuation and it
sounds like you should either try to
work these out with your wife or just
leave or man maybe you know
realistically you probably are not in
love with your wife
it doesn't sound like you are in love
with your wife it sounds like you were
at one time but I don't know if that is
that time anymore you know and you know
you talked for a second about taking
care of your body but are you taking
care only of the outside that's here
that's when I'm a little bit worried
about you know so I look inside of
really ask yourself some questions and
that anxiety that vomit like the only
thing that can be coming from is your
actions are probably more you know
stirring up inside of you and making
your body in your spirit all squirrely
because if you're just talking to your
wife about the sex part but then you're
using that conversation to go then and
justify your actions you know it's not
that's probably you know it's probably
not the coolest way to go about [ __ ] you
know I mean you can cheat on your wife
you can go out and sleep around and see
if that works
see if that
maybe that's the thing you need to do
that's going to help you figure out what
you need to do you know if you need to
stay with your wife or if you need to go
on or but it sounds like you need to
figure out some that doesn't have
anything to do with your wife I think it
has to do with you so I would start
there to solve what you won and and then
take the actions to make the changes you
can do it bro if you need to you can do
it you know but yeah it's hard man it's
hard it's hard to be in a relationship
these days and I think a lot of men
honestly are not even looking really for
lovers in relationships these days I
think a lot of men are looking for
mothers and I base that on the fact that
I'm basing on the fact that I think we
like the recent generation of men has
grown up in a time when they didn't have
mothers a lot of their mothers working
and so they didn't have the same mother
ship that that our grandparents had or
that our parents had so whereas our
parents might have been looking for
sexual mate you know that I think the
men now are looking for something a
little bit more along the motherly lines
and and maybe you're not one of those
men you know maybe your minutes just
looking for that you know you have to
have that second you have to have the
sex in your relationship I know you have
to have it and some people might only be
a few months you know because as you
stay married or some people just they
just become really good friends and sex
isn't that important to them but if
you're probably you know getting back
into your body and taking care of
yourself then yeah you might be you know
we you know revving up that sex dragon
you know you might be feeding matches to
that sex dragon and then he gonna spray
out and you're gonna start talking fire
and that's a your libido is getting lit
up you know you're switching from a from
a from a from 87 to a 91 octane you know
so you starting to run on diesel boy and
that's what it is I think is that you
you're invigorated and you wanna you
want that action again and maybe your
wife is just not full circle there so I
mean the options are you go out and
cheat or you you know let your wife know
what's really going on you stay out and
then you that way you can go out and at
least
the be with another woman and but have a
clean heart about it you know but uh but
good luck man let us know how it goes if
you will once you hit the hotline back
and let us know how it goes and and
Trevor - they called it a little bit ago
well I'd love you to call back and let
us know about what happened in those
saunas when those men was being wild
because I've been in there boy this
gorillas in the mist in there you know I
mean you think it's your towel and it's
another man well sometimes if you have
long hair you'll put his hair right by
your hand and you reach over to get you
think it's your towel but it's his hair
that he's laid out flat on the stone in
there in the sauna and then you grab his
hair next thing you know you pull him
over by you and you think you're just
trying to get a towel or just wipe off
so a lot of trickery and miss currency
going on out there the Disney at nummies
like that or let's keep it moving here
man let's hit another question right
here let's hear it
50 oh this is Derek
I'm from Q of Hawaii Oh Derek from Hilo
Hawaii pineapple country huh what's up
you little napple they call them apples
out there people that um live in a ye on
word and I was just listening to the
last podcast you got talking about how
you might just cut off your balls not
cut off with your dick and because you
get nothing done cuz that and I had to
stop the podcast right there and call
you because that is crazy man you can't
think you would do nothing now he's
referring you know I thought many times
that my penis and um and my junk nuts
and then whatever else is in your nut
sack
they say nuts but it feels like honestly
there's more in there and I thought for
a long time that if I didn't have that
if I didn't have my penis and nuts that
I could function better that I would get
more work done you know because I think
we're starting to become and I believe
that Richard nice
said that I would mail them or Derek
sorry I said that I would mail them to
Africa or to you know a different
country not Africa or Africa or a
different country and because that would
be a meal you know you can easily feed a
family of three or four with the meat
that is inside of your you know your
[ __ ] and your scrotum and I'm not trying
to be discussing but that's real you
know in America we cut off body parts
like it's nothing you know somebody gets
a little bit of gangrene they lock their
leg off but whereas you don't realize is
that in India metal feed a that will
feed a [ __ ] farmer that will feed a
farmer's family you know that will feed
a farmer's family for you know for you
know filling their falafels we're
starting to sound like a uh that will
feed a farmer's family for for filling
their falafels this is starting to sound
like a tongue twister that will feed a
farmer's family for Pattullo or filling
their falafels that will feed a farmer's
family for filling their falafels yeah
it's pretty fun when then the easy one I
think you could what kind of a starter
tongue twister but uh but yeah I think
you can cut it off and mail it rich
Derek and I don't see a problem with
that I don't see a problem providing um
you know some some light food or light
fare to to some others who are in need
and if I don't want my penis and I don't
want my nuts anymore but let's hear the
rest you would get nothing done without
your balls and dick you're motivating
factors for life would be over what
would be the reason it is what would be
the reason it is okay you know I'll
answer that for you the reason to live
then would be I think I think we're
starting to metastasize as humans we're
starting to morph some where yes it used
to be that to procreate was our main
necessity but is it still you know we
have a lot of people in the world we are
at a level especially in America of
pretty high comfort you know we are
pretty comfortable
even if we are even even if we were I
feel like wealthy or poor we are at
least you can be just lazy and you know
collect money or get your money and you
can still be comfortable you can still
have a bed and air conditioning and a
phone and cable and you can have food
and you can be comfortable so at that
point is are we really looking at
procreate as much as we are just looking
to enjoy our comforts I almost feel like
sadly in this country that that's one of
the infestations that we have is that
we're just too comfortable and we're
starting to as humans in America we're
starting to metastasize or we're
starting to evolve into creatures that
it's just like what's the best way we
can enjoy our comfort or the best way
that we can work harder or the best way
that we can but not work harder like in
the sense I need to be in the wild
hunting bores or hunting you know
violent squirrels or flocks of squirrels
or gang of squirrels but in the sense
that I need to be doing you know
computer work or podcasting or you know
stuff that doesn't even need my my dick
and nuts for you know stuff that I need
just my brain and just my ideas for so I
feel like that's where we're at a little
bit so if I didn't have this this this
hindrance of meat between my legs this
meal and I say meal because I got a
decent dick you know I got some swell
[ __ ] for a man and if you and if you if
I'm just carrying it around and somebody
else in another country could this could
be a feast for them a small fees but a
feast for maybe at least a beautiful
Valentine's dinner some if a somebody
wants to enjoy themselves with their
friend or lover but you know then that's
me being greedy and if I and if it
didn't if it if my penis wasn't always
taking my thoughts because I'll start
getting some good ideas and doing work
and my penis is like hey don't you want
to uh you know go see if there's some uh
cooter across the street Oh what if
there's some cooter downstairs huh you
thought about that racin
yeah my penis starts telling me all that
you know it scooter hungry and it'd be
nice sometimes to stop that hunger you
notice ass satisfy it and just to
eliminate it so then I could just stay
in my realm of work and what I feel like
would be to do my best work and to focus
more on the things that help me feel
good about myself like caring about
others you know loving my friends and
family and in trying to be of service
you know those things that really made
me feel good so I don't know man it's
interesting interesting but I feel like
getting rid of it that's what it would
do man
it would really lift me up as a man as a
person I really do what else do we have
here
you know what I got a couple of other
good calls but I'm going to hit them
next week man just is getting late it's
12:45 here and I know some you guys like
what do what we listen it what I'm sorry
man you know I love you doing the best
that I can
I am actually looking forward to
hopefully getting some new studio
environment at at in Los Angeles this
week so hopefully that will come to
fruition but I'm really excited about it
but I appreciate the calls man and I
thank you for the calls and again I
really thank you I appreciate people
that are calling in and sharing what's
going on in their lives and I don't have
any answers all I have are some
suggestions and and what I can share
with you but that's it man coming to you
from Orlando I didn't have any intro or
outro music this week I'll get back to
it I promise but you can hit the hotline
and if you have any other thoughts on
anything that we talked about or brought
up please share them my number is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and it's up for up to three
minutes you can talk on there and if you
don't get it all in then call back but
try to get it all in in three minutes
you know I'm saying but I did get some
other great calls I'm going to use them
I'm just not going to be able to use
them on this
pisode but thank you guys so much have a
great week
it's it's July you know it's summer it's
hot as hell dude it's hot as hell so get
in the pool
you know spray some water on your friend
bring a water bottle squirt somebody you
know I'm Sam brush your teeth though
brush your teeth hug somebody once you
do that once you surprise somebody today
and hug them hug them I'll [ __ ] your
family hug them up huh that's what I
would love to see these gangs I get
tired of watch the news and New Orleans
and I see these people showing up this
beating each other and I would love to
see some you know two gangbangers that
show up in this hug the [ __ ] out of
somebody like [ __ ] you just got
hugged you know damn you feel that joy
[ __ ] but it's hard with the
profanity be good to yourselves man I
bet you deserve it
and if you need me reach out I love you
talk to you guys next week
this has been this past weekend